The Fascinating Origin of the Word “Abracadabra”
These days you might hear Abracadabra before
some stage magician pulls a rabbit out of
his hat, but hundreds of years ago people
actually believed that “abracadabra” was
a magical spell.
The exact origin of the word is up for debate,
but perhaps one of the oldest records we have
of “Abracadabra” being used is a snippet
from a Roman sage named Serenus Sammonicus
in the 2nd century AD from his Liber Medicinalis:
“The malady the Greeks call hemitritaeos
is more deadly.
None of our ancestors could name this disease
in our own language, nor did they feel the
need to.
On a piece of parchment, write the so-called
‘abracadabra’ several times, repeating
it on the line below; but take off the end,
so that gradually individual letters, which
you will take away each time, are missing
from the word.
Continue until the (last) letter makes the
apex of a cone.
Remember to wind this with linen and hang
it around the neck.
Many people say that the lard of a lion is
effective . . .”
It’s unlikely that Sammonicus came up with
the word on his own and it is thought to have
been in use before then.
There are a couple of theories as to where
it might have ultimately come from.
First, it could have been derived from the
equally magical word “abraxas” whose letters,
in Greek numerology, add up to 365—the number
of days in the year.
It could be that early sages thought this
was a powerful word and somehow created “abracadabra”
out of it and turned it into a “cure.”
Alternatively, the word might be derived from
the Hebrew words for “father, son, and holy
spirit”: “ab, ben, and ruach hakodesh”
respectively.
Perhaps more intuitively, it could be derived
from and Aramaic phrase “avra kadavra.”
Harry Potter fans will likely know that this
is what JK Rowling used when she was coming
up with the killing curse “avada kedavra.”
In an interview, she stated that the original
phrase meant “let the thing be destroyed,”
though there is some debate on whether she
is correct on this.
Nonetheless, this would suit the cure-theory
well; abracadabra was written to “destroy”
the sickness.
As strange as it may seem today, people did
wear talismans of sorts with the “abracadabra”
cone as Sammonicus described.
It was thought to cure diseases, fever, and
other problems by siphoning it out of the
person and expelling it through that bottom
“A”.
Obviously it would have no more than a placebo
effect on the user, but people seem to put
a lot of stock in it.
For example, in the 1500s Eva Rimmington Taylor
wrote The Troublesome Voyage of Capt. Edward
Fenton, in which she claimed:
“Banester sayth yt he healed 200 in one
yer of an ague by hanging abracadabra about
their necks.”
Abracadabra was still used as a “cure”
well into the 18th century, as evidenced by
a 1722 book by Daniel Defoe titled Journal
of Plague Year, which lamented the use of
such charms:
“People deceiv’d; and this was in wearing
Charms, Philters, Exorcisms, Amulets, and
I know not what Preparations, to fortify the
Body with them against the Plague; as if the
Plague was but a kind of a Possession of an
evil Spirit; and that it was to be kept off
with Crossings, Signs of the Zodiac, Papers
tied up with so many Knots; and certain Words,
or Figures written on them, as particularly
the Word Abracadabra, form’d in Triangle,
or Pyramid…
How the poor People found the Insufficiency
of those things, and how many of them were
afterwards carried away in the Dead-Carts.”
Eventually, people let go of the abracadabra
superstition and by the 19th century the practice
of hanging an abracadabra charm around your
neck to cure disease had died down.
At this point, the word started to take on
the meaning of “fake magic” which is what
we know today—after all, magicians don’t
actually make rabbits appear out of thin air…
or do they?!?
Bonus Facts:
• “Kadavra” in Turkish means “cadaver”
or “corpse.”
• Many other Harry Potter spells have a
Latin origin: Expelliarmus, the disarming
charm, combines expellere, to drive or force
out, with arma, or weapon, making it “to
force out a weapon.”
Lumos, the wand-lighting spell, derives from
lumen, meaning light.
Crucio, or the Cruciatus Curse, is a torturing
spell that translates to “I torture.”
• Hocus Pocus, another common phrase used
for fake magic, didn’t come about until
the 17th century when a conjurer came up with
the phrase for part of his act: “Hocus pocus,
tontus talontus, vade celeriter jubeo.”
It’s entirely possible that this was derived
from the phrase spoken at Catholic Mass: “hoc
est enim corpus meum,” or “for this is
my body.”
Another theory is that it derives from the
Norse demon Ochus Bochus, and calling his
name would make him help with whatever magic
was meant to be done.
It’s possible that “hocus pocus” later
evolved into the word “hoax.”
• “Presto” simply means “quickly”
in Italian.
It was used by magicians who were attempting
to call up demons and apparently wanted them
to hurry up.